name is Alex Morris I'm 48 years old
from Warwick Rhode Island what I like
most about bladesmithing is it's
challenging and I believe that if we
don't challenge ourselves we don't grow
my name is Charlie Bridges I'm active
duty Army stationed in Fort Sill
Oklahoma
I spend every day at work with so many
soldiers that I can't keep track but
when I get home I get to turn all of it
off throw a piece of Steel into my Forge
and I get to make something out of
nothing
my name is Adam coonrod and I'm a
firefighter paramedic in City Troy New
York my wife and my kids are very
supportive and like that I do knife
making my two children they're both
makers as well and I couldn't be any
prouder of both of them today gentlemen
we're flipping the script you guys are
telling us what your challenge is going
to be
we're gonna make a buoy in a go my
fashion blade length is going to be 10
inches 15 inches overall
two inches at its widest point and two
additional parameters would be two
handle types in the handle and a lanyard
hole good luck work hard your time
starts now I understand go Maya and I
like to make it I have three pieces of
1095 put 15 and 20 on the outside of
them and then a single piece of 1095 on
the outside of that I have a much better
time getting a forged weld on shorter
pieces of Steel than I do of trying to
forge weld a six inch bar
I want to ensure that I have enough
steel to draw out completely but I also
want to make sure that my center with
the testing is going to be done the edge
is all 1095 high carb now I just gotta
wait for it to get up to forge
temperature
well I'm waiting for my Billet to heat
up to proper temperature I'm going to
preheat my dyes so when you do go into
the press it doesn't draw out that heat
as quickly I know that it gives me a
little bit more working time so I can
set those welds I'm feeling very happy
about my welds
oh yeah
I think I've got the right length to
start my blade so now it's time for me
to go in and actually Define a tip no I
find it's ironic Charlie wanted to go
gold my because he wanted a thicker
blade and it it's already very lean
a rough hammer out my handle area then I
start working towards the tip to start
drawing out the clip point on the end of
the Bowie knife this is a lot of Steel
to try to move with my hammer I don't
want to waste any more time so I head
over to the Press I'm running out of
time
well that's a skinny knife
I'm done with the blade I don't want to
mess with that anymore I don't want to
add any more stress
and there's a quench at a very hot
temperature screaming off
bottle check it
I didn't get a hardened blade this just
hit me like a freight train it was
catching a couple of times back in the
Forge what he should do is let the blade
cool all the way down
then file test you're not going to get a
correct skating when it's that hot
I have just put a lot of stress on my
blade I am terrified to go back into the
clinch every single punch putting more
and more stress down that weight
[Music]
I've got a hardened blade total sigh of
relief
last big thing is the quench
file skated off so I'm confident that I
have a hard blade not bad for my first
goal mine
so far I got everything where I wanted
so I say a little prayer and I go for
the quench
I notice that warp started forming whoa
Adam's is warping in the Vise like
really bad wow I don't want to go back
and for another quench because I don't
want to stress that blade anymore but I
need to correct it oh my gosh what I'm
gonna do is I'm three pin technique
while I'm waiting for this to cool down
there's a little bit of a temperature
you can fuss around with it and
straighten it
I've already quenched this is so
dangerous I'm at eye level looking at my
blade looking at the judges looking at
my blade I'm seeing them cringe
Louise ah got my heart palpitated I'm
not getting the warp out as good as I
want but I'm gonna just move on because
I'm running out of time
[Applause]
all right Blaze Miss congratulations the
three of you guys are moving forward
into round two the competition where
you're gonna add handles to your blades
turn them into fully functioning weapons
well you will have two hours in round
two the competition good luck that time
starts now
I'm feeling pretty good about my blade
now I'm gonna head over and start
getting my scales ready my plan is to
cut a thin slice of G10 to use as a
liner and then the Ironwood fully on the
outside of that sandwich together
I'm going to start getting my handle
stock fastened when I'm trying to get
Fasteners together but it's dancing
around on me
it's not wanting to play along
Charlie's using his face yes it's a
third hand principle you have one hand
two hands and the face is the third hand
finally
everything looks solid so now it's time
for me to start getting this handle into
a shape
so don't get rid of epoxy this all
together everything seems to be fitting
up nice I'm going to put it in the Vise
so it's clamped together while it sets
I'm going to use the G10 as the inner
layer and sandwich that with the iron
wood I start putting my handle materials
together I run into a problem trying to
make the pin holes line up I can feel
the epoxy start to set up at this point
I am so stressed out I'm making little
mistakes I'm not thinking things through
he's worked himself into a puzzle
they're still not matching up are they
so he's making basically a hot mess
I don't have enough time to make another
set of handles
I need to correct it quickly I think I
have enough material left in the handle
so if I flip it around it will still
line up Adam has decided just to put
those on all cattywampus it looks like I
got one handle hanging off the edge I
got one hanging over the blade but you
know why there's still enough material I
can grind that and flush it up and it's
not going to be a big issue
while I'm finishing up I think it feels
good but I feel a little slick spot at
the back of my handle so I add some
jimping he's doing a little gym thing so
your thumb doesn't move around because
last thing I want is for Dave Jay or
Doug to swing it and say that it wants
to come out of their hands
I'm gonna go with a short convex Edge
because that should hold up well against
the antler job I'm trying to find a
happy medium here with this blade I want
it to cut but to get to that point I
have to make it survive the antler shop
I think Adam might be happy with his
handle looks like he's working on his
head
well that's a good comeback from Adam
because earlier he was really having a
tough time with that handle three two
one gentlemen turn off your machines put
down your tools this round is over
all right Smiths this is one of the
tests I enjoy the antler shop
now I'm going to take your blades and
beat them repeatedly and mercilessly
into these antlers not only will it test
the edge retention for your heat treat
the overall construction of your knives
themselves Alex how you feeling bud I'm
all right all right let's get to it
good job Alex you survived your Edge is
perfect nothing rolled no glinting
everything's straight good job are you
hey Charlie how you feeling bud pretty
good I feel good too
one more
all right Charlie you survived you
actually made a very comfortable handle
so good job on that but we are missing a
few pieces of your Edge
I could see that grain is pretty coarse
it was pretty high temperature during
quenching but everything else is still
tight good job thank you
all right Adam how you thinking
let her rent
you survived Adam good job your Edge is
good you didn't lose anything nothing
came loose good job
welcome to the sharpness test now to
find out how sharp your weapons are I
will try to slice through these fabric
bags
actual first you ready for this sir
let's do this
all right Alex talk about your weapon
here the balance feels good now your
edge razor sharp every movement cut
cleanly nothing is frayed and overall
sir your blade you look at it nice
all right Charlie your turn sir you
ready let's do it
all right trying to talk about your
blade here it cuts nicely the chips that
you have on your edge here were not a
factor at all overall sir you look at it
thank you
all right Adam are you ready yes sir
let's do this
right Adam your Edge is sharp it took no
damage during the strength test it's
razor sharp Cuts cleanly with a fabric
bag
overall sir your blade you will cut
thank you
all right gentlemen will the judges have
made the decision the blade Smith going
home is
Charlie unfortunately just didn't make
the cut Jay's going to tell you why
Charlie during a strength test you're
the only one that took damage so that's
why we're sending you home I understand
Charlie you've fought really hard and
you did a phenomenal job but it really
just came down to that heat treat
unfortunately not moving forward in
round three of the competition I'm gonna
have to ask you to please leave the
forge all right thank you
Jim well done man good job man although
I'm not happy with the outcome I
understand why but
I enjoyed the whole thing
working around other guys who can forge
a blade that was a ton of fun for me